hey guys Mary here with Alexa ray Korea
and we just finished oxen-free actually
I've played through it once but you
played through it five times five four
and five okay
there's been a lot of playthroughs of
oxen-free and we wanted to give you guys
a little bit of an overview about it
what we felt about it the different
mechanics and kind of just deep dive
into it a little bit but we won't be
giving out too many spoilers so if you
haven't played it before this won't give
away the whole game so I'll be good you
should feel comfortable to stick around
now it just as like a brief overview for
anyone who's never heard of this game
before you you are a teenager that's
kind of embarking on a weekend getaway
yeah it's like an overnight you're going
to this tourist trap e island near your
hometown for a raucous party and you're
with four other people who are not not
all them are your friends and everything
goes haywire when you accidentally
unleash a paranormal entity or entities
it's sort of ambiguous in the beginning
on the island and you have to figure out
how to get away from them and make sure
everyone survives or make sure not
everyone survives if you don't like them
yes some people probably might compare
this to until dawn in the sense where
like your decisions could impact whether
or not people make it off the island and
notify and some people might want to
compare it to life is strange because
there's a lot of dynamics in the
characters and how they interact with
each other and based on how you talk to
them based on how you what you say to
them or if you interrupt them you can
actually disrupt the the dynamic of the
group make people not like each other or
not oh yeah you yeah you can be a total
jerk and people will be a jerk right
back or you could be everyone's best
friend and everyone will toe the line
and help you with whatever you need you
could also you know talk smack about
each other to the other characters and
they will either you know break apart
and they won't interact as nicely or
they might get together with someone
else you could break up a crush which is
that true teenager way which is to be
super nice to your face and then talk
about [ __ ] behind their back that's the
most honest highschool reaction I could
think of but in addition so I kind of
like these weird dynamics they do a
really cool thing with them
Kanak of that hmm where how they how
they showcase what you've said and how
it affected the other character what it
does is you know if you say something
crappy to another player or like to
another person a little space will will
appear above them that's either negative
or positive based on what you made them
feel about you so for example if I say
to you like that that's the shirt you
decided to wear today okay usually
that's like cool reaction to now and I
know that I've upset Alexa likes to has
a negative reaction to me because
because I was a dick but at least I said
it to your face yeah always a plus I
mean something out of it and then this
is all showcased it's all culminated in
a selfie that's taken multiple times
throughout the game and when they take
these selfies you'll see certain
characters that are off by themselves
because they had a bad experience from
maybe what you said or maybe two people
start getting romantic because
hand-holding you're not gonna thing
bringing it together so based on what
you're doing these selfies will change
the characters relationships forever
yeah everything at the end of the game
how each character ends up is entirely
up to you playing as Alex in speaking
with them and the way that you interact
with the environment and it could go
many many ways I've played through five
times and there are still things that
I'm realizing I haven't really
discovered yet or choices that I haven't
taken yet so there's a lot there but
more so than just your interactions with
the other characters there's lots of
stuff that you can find out the world
there's these anomalies that kind of
look like piles of rocks yes and your
main device is the radio if you tune it
at the right time during an anomaly you
learn a little bit yeah you'll hear like
an audio clip of something that reveals
a little bit about the island again
don't want to get into it too much and
then there's those optional letters that
also go into what's going on in the
island and the people that that used to
live there there's a lot of optional
stuff that you can choose to learn about
or wing it I chose most the time not to
learn anything because that's how my
vacations go I'm on vacation so I'm
gonna like drink by the fire I'm not
like
about the history of this island whereas
like Alexa was like learning every
little thing and that actually did
change what happens towards the in the
game which is fascinating it could be
for the better or for the worse
not you know learning everything isn't
always a good thing well I was more
informed and so their ignorance is
famous so that was pretty much like an
overview of it like how did you feel at
the end like are you like super stoked
about it what did you enjoy your time
with it five times is a lot of your time
well I'm I have started a sixth I
haven't finished it yet my gonna want to
go back and find one more thing there's
one more thing I gotta find um but I
really liked it I thought it really
nailed that teenage dynamic of oh we're
like at the end of our high school years
we're trying to figure out who we are
and also there's this girl that I don't
like I don't know why she doesn't like
me and there's this guy it's own best
friend he's kind of weird he likes this
girl I don't know why he likes her she's
kind of crappy and all of that and I
really liked that sort of breakfast club
type dynamic layered on top of this like
poltergeist like plot I like the options
of like thinking that somebody might die
and you might be the cause of it so
that's what I enjoy
Lex is all about the drama bombs and I'm
just looking for some teenagers to like
eat it so you guys like the kind of
stuff this game might be up your alley
it came out today oh you see an xbox one
and it's coming out sometime in the near
future on ps4 so you might want to look
up alright well that's about it for us
so thanks for watching guys